hi everyone it's jerry i'm on chess.com
tactics train i'm going to try three
puzzles and just share my thoughts along
the way so in this one we're white
okay
um this square is very appealing
our rook is attacked
and
oh
oh we're gonna allow our rook to get
captured actually with this one
queen to g3
he's hit once defended one so i'm
looking to attack this unprotected piece
queen g3 and there's not a way to defend
black is very underdeveloped
queen g3
no king move is going to be helpful no
rook move pawn move there's no there's
no good moves except to take the rook
with check
and after the king recaptures there's
another check with bishop h3
but
we just scoot out of the way king to g1
there's probably other moves as well
let me just make certain
i don't think this is too sophisticated
after queen g3 pawn takes king takes
bishop h3
we could play i believe multiple moves
king to e1 even
yeah i think that'll be good enough
there won't be any bishop checks there's
there's one more
hm
maybe actually just back to g1 yeah
that's fine queen g3 pawn takes
king takes bishop h3 king to g1
i for a second was thinking queen v6 i
didn't want to allow but the knights
guarding that
yeah so let's go with it queen g3
king takes okay that's as far as they're
going all right let's try
puzzle two here and this one looks super
familiar
hmm
well i don't know super familiar but
something
with these bishops i've seen puzzles
like this before
so these two squares are covered
i'm trying to get these two covered
right here c1 and b2
so there is this move queen c5
threatening queen here
um
oh you know what another idea might be
to actually capture on b3
oh
i think that's the solution
queen takes b3 is threatening multiple
mates
the only way to prevent it is to
interpose with the queen on one of these
two in which case we'll just take
and the others to take the queen and
after rook takes
how do you stop rook to be one mate
it's interesting that we could arrive at
a position like that
and there'd be just no defense he's not
going to do anything to bother us
and white doesn't have coordination on
these light squares
it's only one piece that could be
playing to these two squares the queen
so this this diagonal in other words
will stay unobstructed
there's no way to prevent
black
or there's no way to prevent black's
bishop here from
maintaining control over both c2 and b1
so queen takes pawn takes rook takes
if the bishop moves
anywhere
well he only has two choices
and in both cases it would be bishop to
d3
check
with then the follow-up
of rook to b1
if queen takes pawn pawn takes rook
takes bishop here if we give a check
immediately
the king runs here
and i don't know that there would be a
mate
i think the solution will be queen takes
pawn takes rook takes
the bishop will move
and then we need to make this move first
with check
making certain that our rook
will control d2 and then we follow up
with mate on b1
all right that is correct this is the
idea with this puzzle
and
check and then finally mate
cool all right let's try last one here
puzzle three oh i'm not gonna like this
one that's my first thought
hmm
team white
uh puzzles like these can
really be a pain
a lot of calculations sometimes is
needed here
okay
um
well
for starters we can do what
there's a night check here
on e3
there's a check on f6
pawn would just take
this is the one i'm drawn to immediately
knight to e3
if we're taking the rook black gets the
move back i don't even want to go in
this direction where we take
because after the night recaptures there
we need to find a place to move with our
king and then black has a free hand to
do whatever on their next turn
it's probably not the direction of going
so i'm discounting this move altogether
well
i don't want to consider it first maybe
i should state it like that
i'm more so looking at
knight e3 check
knight e3 check and then what
are there any other checks queen takes
knight
that's nothing fantastic
hmm
all right let's try this first 93 check
the king has
three options
is there anyone i could eliminate
right away
not sure
what's also worth noting is that after
this check is played and the king moves
like to let's say c6 or taking the pawn
black is ready to come right down here
on a2
so we'll have to follow up in other
words if knight e3 is to be the first
move
we'll really have to be quite forceful
with our ensuing moves knight e3
suppose king takes pawn
i think on that we have queen f5 king d6
queen c5
and then
i think at the very least we'll be able
to then scoop up the rook
of course the king has other options
though
on knight e3 the king doesn't have to
take the pawn
suppose after knight e3 check there's
king c6
oh my goodness i just saw the answer
i mean i didn't see the ends i found the
answer i wasn't reading it or anything
but i just something just came to me
here
let me just try and do my best to
express my thought that just ran through
in a blink right there
um
i recognized this was a pinned piece
and i thought to myself
attack this pinned piece
the move here is
wow this is a cool one
this is a good one to end with
queen c4
because this
is mate
that was a cool puzzle
oh man the alternative is what exactly
actually
there is no alternative the king must
take i was thinking if the king goes
somewhere else we just get the queen
oh man that's a maintenance too
i'm glad i didn't go too lengthy into
all these there i think there were other
variations i could have been going
down but wow
queen c2 that is a cool puzzle
i'm glad i found that one i would have
been kicking myself if i didn't get that
one
but that was a that was a very cool shot
man
okay well
does it feel free to share how you did
with these three especially this last
one
what a cool finish that was
and uh again feel free to share how you
did with
all of them and i'll catch you in the
next video take care bye